and we're joined tonight by kate andrews
economics correspondent and spectator
and sebastian payne whitehall editor of
the financial times welcome to you both
good evening let's start
with the the guardian
and their headline russia escalates war
in ukraine with attack close to nato
border
and this is uh the attack just some uh
15 miles we believe from the border with
poland an escalation of the uh the
attack on on ukraine and the
analysis has been that actually it's
it's close to an attack on nato
sebastian
yes it's clearly a warning shot russia
have done um to obviously try and
threaten and intimidate the west
particularly um the nato countries who
have been putting many weapons and goods
to help the ukrainian war effort and
this has been a very deadly attack
according to the guardian tomorrow um 20
at least 35 people have been killed in
134 injured this really was pretty
significant and as i said it was very
much designed to intimidate and suggest
the fact that this is not going to plan
and they want to try and stop the supply
of weapons but i think in fact it will
have the opposite effect because i think
many of the western countries have seen
that this has not gone to plan for
president vladimir putin and if you look
at the statement from boris johnson who
spoke to president zielinski of ukraine
this afternoon and the west is still
looking at trying to get more equipment
out to ukraine be it things like
generators be weapons whatever it is to
try and help that particular war effort
so it sort of smacks a bit of
desperation but of course as has been
written about extensively over the past
couple of weeks having a leader like
putin who um it does not necessarily
operate the normal bounds and is happy
to try and push things and push that
madman theory forward is not a
comfortable place to be but i think for
the west following this incident it's
times to calm hold their nerves and keep
folks on the strategy which is to supply
the ukrainian forces not get directly
involved and crucially not get involved
in a tit-for-tat with russia because
that's something that could escalate
very quickly and president joe biden of
the u.s said this weekend that's the one
thing he doesn't want to happen so if
putin was trying to trigger some
response i don't think you're
necessarily going to see it from this
awful attack although we have heard from
the the u.s national security adviser
jake sullivan uh quoted in the guardian
warning that any fire even accidental on
a neighboring nato country would trigger
a full force nato response kate what
whatever that means
well this is why putin's attack on the
military base just 15 miles from the
polish border is so worrying because
as we have discovered over the past few
weeks we just don't know how far he
would go and attacking one nato country
is seen under the treaty as attacking
all nato countries it's very difficult
to define what full force would mean
there it still seems that most western
countries are not interested on in a
boots on the ground approach as
sebastian they want to keep supplying
ukrainian
forces with weapons but they do not want
to actually intervene themselves the
question now is is how far putin will
push that theory and does he want
that theory does he want to test the
west when he has tested the west over
the past few weeks it has only united
these european countries that were seen
to be on very taking very different
approaches uh even just a month ago you
now have countries like germany and even
sweden pledging to up their defense
spending something that
you would not have expected to see mere
weeks ago so so far it has created unity
but you know these are these are
obviously very troubling signs from
putin that he's getting so close to the
polish border and of course it's it's
also very close to the city of lev in
the western ukraine which up until very
very recently was seen as a place where
you weren't getting those full-scale
attacks that we've seen in other parts
of ukraine the fact that putin is
pushing his troops even further into
ukraine is very worrying for the people
who of course are still there still
fighting and taking cover
and sebastian we have heard from russia
that this is a a deliberate uh target
that they are targeting those that are a
corridor to uh in terms of military um
assistance to ukraine so it's not it's
not by chance and this is perhaps
something that that will be pursued
further in future
well indeed and just to come back
briefly to your earlier point about the
potential attack on a nato country the
key thing that we've seen from putin's
strategy so far is to push the line but
not to go over it so he knew by
attacking your base 15 miles from the
border exactly what message would send
but it was not an attack on poland which
as jake sullivan from the binding
administration said that would list a
full article five response for nato
which means attack on one is an attack
on all the members so i think putin will
keep doing that but don't forget he went
into this war he invaded ukraine with a
specific purpose of trying to
demilitarize the country that's what
they've said in this so-called special
operation is he describes it in an
invasion of wars the rest of the world
has described it so it's no surprise
they're going after these military bases
but we shouldn't forget that that is
obviously a part of the era to try and
win this war which they are struggling
to do but the attacks on civilians are
absolutely appalling and again we've
seen more images over this weekend out
of kiev out of other cities and it's
clear that first of all that there are
war crimes going on here and the
civilian population is being
specifically talented by russian troops
but also that you know this is a
devastating effect this is having on
ukraine the fact is that kiev was a city
of four million people it's not up to
two million people its population and
some of the images and reporting
suggests it's become a total ghost town
and it's only going to get worse
uh but but also clear um kate that uh
this attack isn't going to deter the
west offering help to ukraine that
that's absolutely clear isn't it
so far it only seems that the the
further putin goes the more the west is
willing to respond by supplying the
ukrainian forces with more weapons with
more cash with more support and
humanitarian aid
of course but also you you have seen
those economic sanctions which are
really starting to crush the russian
economy those reports out of moscow
about you know the economy really
tutoring on collapse people's bank cards
no longer work they can't scan into the
two because apple pay has stopped
working um you know the daily lives of
russians are are being um severely
impacted now which is obviously uh going
to have an impact
we've had thousands of people arrested
in russia for actively protesting so
that there you know part of that will be
a moral perspective on the part of many
russians who are just not happy about
what putin is doing in ukraine uh part
of that will be frustration that their
normal lives are collapsing and it has
taken the uk some time to get its head
around sanctions against individual
oligarchs but you can see almost day by
day uh western countries including the
uk are making advances there they are
willing to go further there are more
steps that the west could take if it
wanted to [ __ ] russia's economy and
it very likely will continue to do so so
so far putin's actions have only
continued to unite the west as sebastian
notes he may be trying to test that
going so close to the polish border with
this latest attack on the military base
he may be trying to see what breaks the
west in their unity so far he hasn't
been able to find that crack all of his
actions have have brought europe and
the uk and america together in a way
that really was never expected to be so
united just weeks ago
and all the while worth noting that uh
peace talks are continuing between
ukraine and uh russia and uh positive
soundings are coming out of those talks
at the moment let's have a look at the
guardian uh sebastian and take us into
this story the former u.n secretary
general ban ki-moon has an environmental
warning for the uk
yes there's been a huge amount of
chatter in westminster over the past
couple of weeks about fracking now the
um sort of digging up of shale gas was
something the uk has explored but it's
all come to quite a bitter end and
there's no all the [ __ ] sites have
been concreted up and among
environmental concerns practical
concerns economic concerns about whether
this was going to be a viable form of
energy production here now it's come
back on the agenda because following the
ukraine crisis and obviously the fact
that uk and the us have um are stopping
buying oil from russia there's been a
lot of pressure on boris johnson to
reinvigorate fracking and some people in
government like the business secretary
quasi quattang have said this is not
something you're looking to it's going
to take 10 years it still might not be
viable viable and it's very difficult to
do in the uk which is a very densely
populated country but then other people
in the tory party say well it works very
well in america we need to get on this
and we need to focus on energy security
not net zero and in this common funky
moon says you know but a very dangerous
point that we should not resile from the
net zero ambition but we can't look at
it doing through fracking which as i
said some people allege is dangerous and
not sustainable but i think it is a very
interesting debate because the uk did
try this there was a moment where
fracking seemed to be a sort of hail
mary pass for the uk's energy production
that now seems to pull back so i imagine
there'll be a lot of noise about this
from mps and number 10 but i'd be very
surprised if it actually goes anywhere
not least due to the objections of local
residents as we saw when fracking was
tried in lancashire last time and came
to a very abrupt end
kate let's uh turn to um the telegraph
we've just got time for this story um
dominic cumberbatch at the uh baftas has
said that he's going to be willing or
he's actually going to go ahead and
house a ukrainian refugee given the
opportunity
yeah so the baptist tonight benedict
cumberbatch has announced that he will
look into hosting a ukrainian refugee
which is something that theoretically
many of us will be able to do here in
the uk when the homes for ukraine scheme
comes into action which has been um now
announced by michael gove the leveling
up secretary there's still a lot of
questions around the scheme the
telegraph reports that they're going to
be there's going to be a lot of
bureaucracy around a lot of hurdles to
jump over people who are hosting
ukrainians are going to go uh through
background checks um there's going to be
uh you have to commit to doing it for at
least six months there's still a lot
more red tape in the uk even with this
new and improved scheme from where we
were a few days ago than there is in the
rest of europe so one does have to
wonder how many extra ukrainian refugees
this will actually allow to be host in
the uk um but this isn't we're in a much
better situation at least now with the
government having innovative uh policy
solutions as to how we can help more
refugees than we were just a few days
ago indeed but as you say uh many
questions still to be answered and
policy to be ironed out i.e how people
will be supported if they do take in
refugees